Uh, someone asked me, uh,
at the end of class on
Tuesday a very good question.
And the question is what exactly is a
broad side? So I was here sort of happily,
oh yes, they're posting
broadsides, don't buy tea.
And I'd never really precisely
define what a broad side was. Um,
a broad side is actually a single sheet
of paper that's something is printed on
one side and it would have been um,
posted in public are handed out in public
like in town squares or taverns and
usually they were advertising things.
We're announcing things that
were of immediate pressing
importance like you know,
immediate news, pressing news, political
events, official proclamations,
great entertainment or whatever.
They were sort of immediate news and
they were not really seen as great
permanent documents. They were seen
as something that you post it up,
you handed out,
you read it for the day or whatever
and then it would be discarded.
So that was these broadsides
or that I was talking about.
The detested t has arrived at airport
would have been that kind of an
announcement. It would have been
an immediate, like the tease here.
Now do something kind of
an instant announcement.
So that's what a broadside is.
Okay,
so today we are going
to make our way to what,
on this syllabus I have called
the logic of resistance.
And what I mean by that is the mindset
that contributed to some of the broad
conclusions that the colonists were
drawing as events were unfolding in the
1770s as we've seen in
the last few lectures.
But to get to the logic of resistance,
we first have to lay out another event
that contributed to the building of that
logic.
And I mentioned it right at the end of
the last lecture and that event is a
series of acts that were passed by
parliament in 1774 and Americans ended up
calling them the intolerable acts,
which being easy way to remember
what they are, the intolerable acts,
they also were called the coercive acts,
but intolerable,
intolerable would have been what
Americans with a communist would have
considered them.
And I mentioned them right at the end
of the last lecture. As you remember,
they were a response to the
destruction of the t in Boston harbor,
which sort of dumbfounded lord north,
who had assumed that his tea act passed
in 1773 was going to be seen as maybe a
relief by the colonies that north have
been trying to save the east India
company from going under.
He had reduced duties on east India tea
so that people will be buying that t
path.
The act thought this would
be seen potentially as a
good thing only to find that
the colonists saw it as an attempt of
the British government to have a monopoly
over what the colonists had assumed was
free trade and that's where you get the
broad sides that I was just talking about
telling people not to buy or sell east
India tea and to do act now,
defend your liberties and then eventually
you end up with the destruction of tea
in Boston harbor.
And as I mentioned in the last lecture,
Boston Tea Party is actually later in
the 19th century that they didn't call
this at the time. They probably called
it the destruction of the tea. Um,
but there was not a party at the time.
That was later they
decided it was a deportee.
So now clearly having had that happen,
north felt that something really
needed to be done about the colonies or
obedience to British law and order in his
mind would collapse in the colonies as
he put it. And I think I quoted this
right at the end of the lecture,
that if they didn't risk something
all is over dramatic statement,
that's you get the intolerable acts which
are passed in the spring of 1774 and
although there were some in
parliament who protested against them,
still they pass with a great majority.
Those who did protest against them argue
that the American colonists deserved
the same rights as any
other British subjects.
And as I described the acts to you,
you will understand why these friends
to America were making this argument.
You'll hear the details and see that their
argument certainly made sense at that
moment.
So there were four apps that get lumped
together as the intolerable acts,
the first one,
the Boston port act,
which closed the port of Boston to all
shipping until the colonists paid for the
tea that they had destroyed.
And I suppose also hopefully showed some
degree of remorse for having destroyed
all that tea.
Now clearly that's a pretty
extreme measure, right?
Closing the port of Boston period.
And North assumed that it would pretty
much crush the opposition in Boston and
that other colonies would scramble for
Boston's lost trade and ignore what was
happening in Boston.
And you will see this again and again,
that there is sort of a
fundamental misunderstanding
about when and what ends up
seeming like a joint threat to the
colonist so that they act together versus
what doesn't inspire them to act together.
So here we see lord north,
assuming that if Boston loses trade,
the other colonies will just sort of
gobble it up. And the Boston radicals,
we'll sort of get silenced and
that'll be the end of this matter.
But he misjudges colonial sentiment in
this case really underestimating the
sense of unity that arises from something
that ends up being seen as a joint
threat.
So the British government ends up being
rather stunned when the other colonies,
not only don't ignore Boston,
but instead they actually
support it in its time of need.
So other colonies responded to the Boston
port act and some of these other acts
by sending goods.
So Connecticut sent sheep,
Charleston sent rice,
Philadelphia sent.
So the other colonies basically stepped
up and did something in Boston's time of
need.
And a lot of colonies made June 1st which
is the day that that act was supposed
to take effect a day
of fasting and prayer.
Now clearly some of this was
because people felt sympathy
for what was happening
in Boston. They they saw and
felt for Boston, and it's plight,
but equally if not more important,
people in other colonies assumed
if it could happen in Boston,
it could happen anywhere.
So in a lot of ways Boston's cause
was there because it wasn't something
happening far away. It was something that
there was no reason why they couldn't.
See it couldn't happen anywhere else where
the British government happened to be
angry at something that happened.
So in essence,
Lord North's actions did the precise
opposite of what they were meant to do
because they really ultimately brought
the colonies closer together in a shared
sense of crisis.
As George Washington put it in his
typical kind of meandering indirect way,
Washington is not always the best word.
Smith Washington had very
good people writing for him.
He could speech makers that Washington.
Um,
but he tends to write kind of a mandarin
style and this will be kind of a
typical Washingtonian statement full
of parentheses and weird clauses,
but he's, he's his heart's
in the right place. Okay.
So Washington says the ministry,
the British Ministry may rely on it.
The Americans will never be
taxed without their own consent.
That the cause of Boston,
the despotic measures in respect to it.
I mean now is and ever will be
considered as the cause of America.
Not that we approve their
conduct and destroying the tee.
This is all one sentence.
And that we shall not suffer ourselves
to be sacrificed by piecemeals.
Though God only knows
what is to become of us.
It's under a Washingtonian sentence,
but still he's making
his point really clearly.
So the Boston port act number
one of the intolerable acts,
the other three still pretty largely
focused on Massachusetts included a
quartering act and the quartering act
legalized the quartering of British
troops,
not only in empty buildings or taverns,
but also in private homes,
the administration of Justice Act,
which was an attempt to protect people
who were trying to suppress revolts in
the colonies.
So the administration of Justice Act
said that if a fair trial for a British
soldier or official couldn't
be had in Massachusetts,
the trial could be transferred
to another colony or to England.
And in Massachusetts, the land
of propaganda. This became
known as the murder act.
Just in case you want to wonder what
people were thinking about it. Um,
and if someone at the time put it,
every villain who ravish his,
our wives or the flowers are daughters
can evade punishment by being tried in
Britain where no evidence can pursue him.
Okay,
we're not really talking so much
about ravishing Indy flowering.
We'd really talking about taxes and such,
but still you could understand the logic,
why people feel that again,
some fundamental liberties are being
violated here. And then finally,
the last of these acts is the
Massachusetts government act.
And in a lot of ways that ended up
being the most controversial act of all
because it basically imposed a new charter
on the colony of Massachusetts from
now on.
The governor who was appointed by the
king could appoint his own counsel rather
than having the council be
elected by the colonial assembly.
The council could not no longer
veto the governor's decisions.
All town meetings besides the one
annual meeting for electing officers now
needed to be approved by the governor.
And if the governor wanted,
he could simply for bid down meetings and
any additional meaning besides the one
in which officers were chosen.
That meeting needed to post an agenda
in advance and stick to the agenda.
And the governor also now could
appoint or remove sheriffs, judges,
attorney generals,
Marshall's.
So basically the is a royal official
and the governor is now in Massachusetts
being given a lot of power.
So I'll repeat the four intolerable acts,
the Boston port act,
the quartering act,
the administration of Justice Act,
and the Massachusetts Government Act.
So having described those acts,
you can see why there would have been
some in parliament who were sympathetic to
what was going on in the colonies,
who would have protested that these acts
were depriving colonists of some pretty
basic British constitutional rights.
But these protesters were in the minority.
Now on top of these acts,
the king sent a new
governor to Massachusetts,
Massachusetts General Thomas Gauge
Commander of the British forces in North
America. Okay, so a military commander
was sent to be the new governor. Again,
a pretty dramatic statement.
So now in addition to all of those acts,
you have the looming threat certainly
to the colonies or the colonists and
Massachusetts have a standing army as
a source of tyranny staring them in the
face.
So certainly people in Massachusetts that
this moment would have been justified
in feeling as though they were
under military occupation.
Now we may look at these pretty drastic
measures and assume that reconciliation
is pretty impossible at this point,
and I know a few of you came up to me
after class on Tuesday and actually we
already leaning in that direction like
when are we getting to independence?
Because how in the world can they get out
of this? Right? It's looking pretty bad.
Look at these really extreme measures.
Certainly it looks as though
rebellion is on the horizon,
but independence is not the natural
choice. I mean, that's a really,
really radical move that is not
at this moment on the horizon.
These are really,
I'm going to talk more about this
in this lecture a little further on.
These are British subjects trying to
demand the rights of British subjects.
That's the logic that's at play here.
They're not thinking independence.
They're thinking that they need to find
a way to get the British imperial system
to work in a way that
they see as being right.
They're not trying to break away.
They're hoping that there's a way to fix
things and that they will get what they
feel they deserve as British subjects.
So in 1774,
it was in the hope of maybe figuring
out some way to settle the thing,
some way to compromise,
some way to come to some
sort of a solution that the
Massachusetts legislature
sent a circular letter to the other
colonies suggesting that it might be smart
to have a joint congress from all the
colonies to discuss their problems and to
figure out a course of
action that made sense.
So what came to be known as the
first Continental Congress, right?
The congress of the continent,
um,
met in Philadelphia at
the end of August in 1774.
Most of the delegates to that Congress
already had some political experience in
their separate colonies.
None of them were absolute uncompromising
radicals who wanted to rip everything
apart.
There's not a sort of dire radical body,
and I'll be talking a little bit more
about the first continental congress in a
lecture to come. But for
now, I'll just state, um,
I guess for significant things
about the meeting of the congress.
Okay. First, and it's
actually kind of practical.
The meeting of the first
continental congress forced
the colonists to make their
beliefs clear to themselves as people
from a variety of different colonies and
to Great Britain and to
explain the motives behind
their actions as they debated
and drafted petitions and
resolves and declarations.
The delegates were clarifying and defining
their thoughts and they were doing it
in a room full of delegates from other
colonies that people didn't necessarily
know that well.
So it was actually just in and of itself.
By collecting all these people together
in a room and forcing them to sort of
think things through,
talk things through and come up
with some kind of a resolution.
They were actually hashing out their
problems on a broad level in a way that
they had not done before.
Second,
continental Congress forced people
from very separate colonies in a way,
really sort of separate nation states
to meet one another and stay with one
another for an extended period of time.
And for a lot of the
people that were there,
this was really their first extended
periods spent with people from far away
colonies.
So not only did this contribute
to a sense of colonial unity,
but it actually on a
really practical level,
it gave people a chance to see how
other colonies ran their colonial
governments. And, and John Adams actually,
he writes a great diary at the time and
in his diary he writes about how when
he's in this congress,
he spent a lot of time grilling
people from other colonies,
asking questions about their charters,
their laws, the logic behind them.
He really wanted to understand
how other colonies worked.
And it's interesting because in his
letters, I think also in his diary,
even in his, in his letters for sure, um,
Adams refers to himself and his position
in the continental congress as our
embassy, right. And by our embassy,
what he means is he sees himself
as a kind of diplomat representing
Massachusetts in a sort of,
you know,
to take today you might
say international body,
but he sees the continental congress as
a sort of grouping of representatives of
other provinces or other
countries or nations.
And he's a delegate from our embassy
of Massachusetts. So, you know,
in a way we put a lot of baggage into
the word Congress as though you know, oh,
it's a bunch of Americans
joined in a congress. Um,
but it's not a congress and our modern
sense of the word it really is in their
mind is sort of delegation of,
of people representing
different nation states,
which is why it was so interesting for
them to collect together and get to
exchange thoughts.
And then third to John
Adams and some others,
the fact that now this
congress existed seem to be,
or at least to hold the potential for
being some kind of a training ground for
American statesman. And
Adam's put it at the time, um,
said that the congress was quote to
be a school of political profits,
I suppose a nursery of American statesman.
May it thrive and prosper and flourish.
And from this fountain may their issues
streams which shoved gladden all the
cities and towns in North
America forever died.
I was always has a way of saying
like the big, broad quotable thing,
which is why I keep coming back to him.
Hello.
I will provide you the
historian with the big, broad,
wonderful quote about the continental
congress. Thank you, John Adams.
I am from making the congress annual
and for sending an entire new set of
delegates every year that
all the principal geniuses
may go to the university in
rotation,
that we may have politicians in Plenti.
Our policy must be to improve
every opportunity and means
for forming our people
and preparing leaders for them
in the grand march of politics.
So he's drawing a lot of big hopes for
the future from the meeting of this
congress.
But certainly he's thinking the fact
that it exists and that these people were
meeting and talking in this way on this
level will be in and of itself a sort of
educational colonial experience.
And then finally,
a fourth significant aspect of the meeting
of this congress was that at least to
some back in England,
the continental congress symbolized
a move towards rebellion.
And indeed more about this to come.
But in February of 1775 lord north passed
a resolution in parliament declaring
that Massachusetts was
in a state of rebellion.
And part of the reason why
it's Massachusetts that
he's focusing on is because
really still in parliament,
they are assuming that Massachusetts
is the ring leader of all the trouble.
The real reason for the
Congress is Massachusetts.
Massachusetts is the problem.
Massachusetts is moving towards rebellion
and to some people back in England
looking on this,
continental Congress looks treasonable.
So you can see how things are evolving.
Here you could see how mutual
misunderstandings are growing.
Colonists and the British administration
are grappling with the real meaning of
British sovereignty in the colonies.
The British government isn't really
clear on some of the logic of colonial
thinking.
On such matters.
Colonists see an ongoing
attempt to violate their
fundamental rights as British
subjects as they have
come to understand them.
Which brings us to the perfect segue into
a discussion of the logic of colonial
resistance,
the logic driving the colonial mindset
during the passage of the 1770s and what
I'm going to do now,
I'm going to introduce this subject
by doing something that's a little bit
illogical,
but I just can't resist it basically.
So you're going to be subject to it.
Um, there actually is a logic to it. Um,
but to talk about the logic of
resistance in the revolution,
I'm going to use a story that actually
dates to a period significantly after the
revolution,
which kind of doesn't make sense but
it does cause the story actually really
wraps up a lot of stuff in it.
And this story relates to a
conversation that took place in 1791.
So it's after the revolution.
The United States has only been in
existence for a few years when the story
takes place and secretary of State,
Thomas Jefferson,
he's almost newly arrived, a secretary
of state, not, not there for that long,
decides he's going to have a little dinner
party to discuss a political question
that's come up and he invites
vice president John Adams
and he invites secretary
of the treasury,
Alexander Hamilton.
The reason why we know this story is
because Jefferson told it a lot, right?
It's because as we'll see Jefferson drug
great deep significance to this little
dinner conversation and he
repeated it over and over again.
And letters and journals,
it's like the story that reveals
the meaning of everything.
But you'll see why won't sound too
dramatic now that I've set it up that way.
But to Jefferson, it was earth shaking.
So little dinner party, Adams, Jefferson,
Hamilton,
and Jefferson who tells the story says
that after they're done with their meal,
quote, our question, agreed and dismissed.
Conversation began on other matters.
The room being hung around
with a collection of the
portraits that remarkable
men among them, those of Bacon, Newton
and lock Hamilton asked me who they were.
So this is how this is Jefferson's home
and in his home are these portraits.
Bacon, Newton and lock. And Hamilton
sitting there as a dinner guest, looks up,
sees the portrait and says, who
are they? Okay. Jefferson says,
I told him they were my trinity of the
three greatest men in the world had ever
produced.
This is professor Jefferson and full
gear naming them Lord Francis Bacon,
the philosopher of science,
Sir Isaac Newton,
the scientist who defined the
laws of gravity. John Locke,
the philosopher of I suppose you
could say the philosopher liberty.
And as Jefferson recalled
hearing this quote,
Hamilton pause for some time.
The greatest man said he that ever
lived was Julius Caesar. Okay.
Now, for reasons that will
become clear in this lecture,
this shocked Jefferson,
I mean like shock Jefferson,
so that he told the story again and
again and again, remember it for decades.
I mean in the 1820s he's still like,
I remember that story,
that dinner where the Hamilton 30 years
ago in which he said the greatest man
who ever lived with Julius Caesar,
he repeated it to him.
It was a sign of the amazing, dangerous
implications of Hamilton's policies.
But I want to pull the story apart. I want
to look at this a little bit as a way,
not really of getting a
Jefferson and Hamilton,
but to get at something of
the intellectual mindset
of Americans during this
period. And some of this has to
do with enlightenment thinking,
and some of this has to do
with constitutional thinking,
but you'll see why both
men said what they said.
Now to start with,
I'm not saying that every single
colonist is sitting around at this point
discussing Bacon, Newton and lock.
Okay, that's not what I mean.
This is a very much a Jeffersonian parlor
with these portraits. Ah, you know,
up on the wall.
Um,
but those three men make a Newton
Locke and others did contribute to an
intellectual atmosphere that the American
colonists tapped into that shaped
their thoughts about rights,
about resistance,
and then eventually about revolution.
So let's start by looking at,
at Jefferson's trinity of
great men. Who were they? Okay,
Sir Francis Bacon,
man of science who believed that truth
discovered by reason through observation
could promote human happiness as well as
truth communicated through God's direct
revelation.
So basically Bacon's work suggested that
it was in humankind's power to discover
truth by reason and that by doing
that humankind could better itself.
Okay, so that's Bacon, Isaac Newton,
a second man of science
who studied gravity and the
laws of motion and Newton's
work demonstrated that it was possible
through reason and to discover the laws
of nature and of nature's God.
So Newton's work suggested that the
world is governed by laws that you could
discover and understand that there's a
cause and effect and that through reason
and study you can figure out the
cause and effect of Nature's laws.
So then onto the third man,
John Locke,
who second treatise on government from
1683 suggested that you could apply
nature's laws to the political world
as well and determine and understand
natural and political rights.
And I'm going to offer here it really
woefully brief summary of locks thoughts
that'll just be enough to give us a
sense of what it is that Jefferson is
getting at here.
Basically,
Locke believed that people weren't born
free unhampered by government and with
certain natural rights,
life,
liberty and property and
that to protect these rights,
people decided to voluntarily leave
this state of nature to form a civil
government contracting some
of their natural rights to
this government when they
did so.
So civil society was created to protect
humankind's three natural rights life,
liberty property. So you could refer
to this as social contract theory.
Logical enough, summing up
of it. If you think about it,
if a civil government is a
kind of voluntary contract,
this suggests that people have a right
to pull out of that contract if their
rights are being violated.
And obviously that will have an
important logic down the road.
Now if you take all of that together,
make a Newton lock and the
logic of their thoughts,
you can see the empowering aspect
of Jefferson's trinity, right?
All of those men in one way or another,
our preaching ideas that
are empowering humankind,
they're suggesting that there are laws
of the universe that could be determined
by people and applied to nature,
to government, to science,
to society in the hope
of bettering things.
They suggested that civil government is
a contract created by and maintained by
people,
not some kind of a divine creation.
And if you step back and consider the
implications of these really broad ideas,
you can see that they share an underlying
conviction that humankind could solve
God's riddles by dissolving,
dissolving, dissolving his laws,
gas discovering and
applying his natural laws.
And in a sense, this is the, the idea
that's the spirit of the enlightenment,
that the world is governed by
natural laws that can be detected,
they can be studied, they can
be applied. And in a sense,
the practice of day Islam
stems from this idea. Um,
there were some founder types
who were basically deus at heart,
believing that God was a sort of divine
clock maker who made a world of logic
and natural laws and then stepped
back and allowed it to operate without
intervening. And this kind of God
is omniscient and all powerful,
but it was natural forces
that governed daily existence
and things that we're governed by
understandable and predictable.
Natural laws could be
detected, analyzed, critiqued,
and applied by man.
So in this sense,
you really can see how some of the spirit
of the enlightenment would have been a
kind of empowering philosophy.
So Jefferson's trinity of portraits
reveals a lot about this kind of general
enlightenment spirit and some of
its intellectual implications.
But what about the
other half of the story?
What about Hamilton's comment about
Julius Caesar and Jefferson's?
I'm going to be shocked for
three decades response. Well,
this aspect of the story reveals another
related aspect of the enlightenment
mentality.
It shows how immediate and relevant
the ancient world and actually history
generally was to enlightenment thinkers
and I suppose just in the 18th century
generally an idea that's again related
to this idea that humankind can detect
patterns and then apply them for all
time because basically if you think about
it, if you believe in
ongoing natural patterns,
you're also going to believe
that the study of history,
all of history is one way to determine
laws and patterns of human nature that
apply across all time.
So basically two people at this period,
all of history,
it was like a big grab bag of lessons
about humankind and civil society,
ancient Greece, ancient Rome, modern
nations, modern peoples and more.
If you study them,
if you look at rules and patterns,
you could find things to apply to modern
times that ideally would allow you to
better things for the present by
learning from the past. And in a way,
the ultimate example of this, I think
I've mentioned it once before in here,
I'm not sure, is James Madison preparing
for the constitutional convention?
Um, and he's very much, he's right
in line with this kind of thinking.
He basically says, I'm going to study
republic's across all time, right?
All of human time.
I will study Republican government and
thinking if he could figure out the rules,
if he could figure out what works and
what doesn't work and see the patterns and
get the rules,
he can then apply that knowledge to
the creation of a new republic that
hopefully then would benefit
from that kind of knowledge.
If I love the fact that
medicine sets out to do that,
write that all down on paper so
you can see how in in this sense,
if you're thinking along these lines,
you can see how ancient history could be
really immediate to this sort of whole
founding generation because it
had real lessons for the present.
And actually one of the most influential
books in educating young gentlemen at
the time was Plutarch's lives.
Has anyone here read Plutarch's?
You must be some flu. It was a couple
plutoch readers in here that's admirable.
Um,
Plutarch's lives is basically a
collection of brief biographies of Great
Statesman and leaders,
ancient Greece, ancient Rome,
and it was aimed at teaching
rules of leadership,
teaching young men how to model themselves
into great leaders are certainly,
that's how it was used
in the 18th century.
Any young man would have read Plutarch's
lives and would have learned, you know,
all the greatest thing I can do is to
be a great statesman and found a nation.
Then here are great
examples for me to follow.
So given this kind of a logic,
there's a good reason why
Hamilton's comment about
Caesar might've been shocking
to Jefferson.
It's not just a little
interesting intellectual sort
of other part of Hamilton.
Oh,
are there,
the greatest man that ever lived is
rules Julius Caesar Pass the Cherries.
I mean,
it's not,
he didn't see this as a sort of random
idle throwaway intellectual comment.
It was a declaration about
present day policies to Jefferson.
And it wasn't a declaration that made
Jefferson happy because think about the
historical lesson that Jefferson
logically pulled from health.
His comment about Julius Caesar,
who was Julius Caesar in short,
he was the man who destroyed
the Roman Republic, okay?
He's the guy who marched his army
against the republic who seized power,
who made himself emperor.
So there we are in 1791 and Alexander
Hamilton in the middle of this experiment
to create a new republic.
No one knows if it's going to work.
It might collapse at any second.
And Alice in her house and says,
the greatest man who ever
lived is Julius Caesar,
the man who destroyed the Roman republic.
Okay? This is why Jefferson was like,
oh my God, what does this mean? What does
this mean? This is the truth to Hamilton,
right?
This is,
this is a bad moment as far as relations
between Jefferson and Hamilton are
concern. The Jefferson Dinner Party I'm
with never lived it down. So to Jefferson,
this is a side to him, this was like he,
the scales were lifted from his eyes,
right? Hamilton wants to be a kind of
Caesar. He's dangerously ambitious.
He wants to destroy the republic.
Maybe he wants to make it go back into a
monarchy and then put himself into some
kind of a position of power.
Like he could just see the pathway laid
all with that one little comment that
Hamilton tossed out at a dinner.
He had to be careful at how you talked
in an age where history meant that much.
Now let's stop for a moment
also to think why did Hamilton,
why did Hamilton say that? Why
did he say that? Um, I mean it's,
it's unlikely that what
he meant to say was, hi,
I'm going to be the next Julius Caesar.
I'm out to destroy the republic.
Nice to meet you.
Okay.
He probably wasn't intending to signal
some big threat to the American republic.
I think that there are probably
two explanations for it.
No one actually ever absolutely
knows why he said this and that's,
it says more about Hamilton
than anything else.
He's wonderfully self destructive
individual Alexander Hamilton.
But in this case, I think there are
two possible reasons why he said this.
One is he actually just liked to
savings to upset down this Jefferson,
you're really good. And this was a
good one. Better than he thought.
But he liked to push Jefferson's buttons,
get Jefferson all sorts of
sputtering and mad and it worked.
Aaron Berg did the same
thing to Alexander Hamilton,
like he would say sort of shocking,
outrageous things and then watched
Hamilton splutter and then Hamilton would
repeat them for years and years and years.
Do you know what he said
at the dinner party?
Dinner parties where tricky places can
maneuver in the early republic. Um,
so part of it might've been just Hamilton
being deliberately irritating, um,
or equally possible.
It's possible that that Hamilton
was referring to Caesar as you know,
a statesman, a leader, a
founder of a nation. Um,
Hamilton would have
admired military ability.
So he would have actually seriously
admired that. And Cesar too.
But he really could have been more
thinking of Caesar as great statesmen,
great leader depicted in Plutarch's
as you know, a model on it.
Certainly in the mind of an educated
gentleman like Hamilton being the founder
of a nation,
being someone who shaping a nation would
have been seen as an admirable thing.
So he could have been
thinking along those lines.
It's interesting when you look
through all of Hamilton's writings,
he doesn't really speak in
praise of Caesar anywhere else,
which might lead you to theory
number one. Okay, teach,
see how you deal with this one.
I'm all for Julius Caesar.
What are you going to do?
No, it's hard to know. Um,
but at any rate it's unclear what,
what Hamilton's logic is.
But you can certainly
understand Jefferson's shocked
response. And either way,
both the comment and the response reveal
the power of the classical heritage on
this early American world.
Both men are applying the past
to the present in some way.
And one of the lessons that Caesar
certainly suggested to Thomas Jefferson as
suggested by his response is a powerful
lesson that a lot of people were focused
on in the early years of the American
republic and in this colonial period is as
well. And that is the fragility
of liberties. And in the republic.
Also obviously how,
how fragile republics are.
So the ancient world held
really valuable lessons,
but so did the semi recent past as well,
particularly for the American colonists.
There was another period of time that
seemed to hold special lessons for them.
The period of the glorious
revolution in Britain,
which would have been a
period when opposition to the
king's Court and ministers
was on the rise in Britain,
along with a growing tradition of praise
for English liberties and the glories
of representation in parliament.
So political rhetoric from the era of the
glorious revolution would have focused
on attacking corruption and corrupt
influence as when a monarch would try to
bribe legislators,
are ministers with high office or
pensions granted from the crown,
thereby subverting the
balanced British constitution,
which is supposed to be balanced
between Crown, Lourdes and Commons.
That would have had some real bearing
on this revolutionary period as well.
But whether talking about history,
ancient or history,
relatively modern history did teach
some overriding lessons that British
subjects would have taken as
their own throughout this period.
And that at this moment in time would
seem really relevant in the American
colonies.
So they're going to be amazingly brief
summary of some of these lessons,
but you'll see really clear lessons
that history would appear to be teaching
generally and the colonists would
be listening to really attentively.
So history taught basically that arbitrary
power is the ultimate threat to good
government.
Okay.
So the 1770s is a moment
when that's certainly going
to be something that people
here history taught that
political liberties were fragile.
History taught that constitutional
principles defended customary contract
Terrian rights against government
assertions of arbitrary power.
So arbitrary power is the ultimate
threat to good government.
Political liberties are fragile and it's
constitutional principles that defend
against governments asserting
arbitrary power. So yes,
Rome had been great, but arbitrary power
had sent it spiraling into tyranny.
The glorious revolution had been a
moment where ancient liberties had been
restored by restraining
the power of the monarch.
So clearly history taught liberty's
fragile and powers the natural enemy.
Arbitrary Power and power
naturally grows by nature.
Power grows. And as it does it encroaches
on liberty's in a free society.
So power has to be restrained.
British liberties must be defended
and British liberties as defined by
generations of constitutional precedents.
Now it's important to remember that the
British constitution is not a written
document like American state
and federal constitutions.
It's a way of thinking about
authority largely based on precedent,
based on existing institutions,
based on laws and customs.
And it was a means of limiting
power and defending rights.
So when British colonial policy began
to change in the mid 18th century,
and precedents seemed to be
abandoned and new precedents,
perhaps we're being set when parliament
seemed to be asserting what certainly to
some colonists felt like arbitrary
power is logically began to worry about
protecting their fundamental British
liberties against seemingly increasingly
arbitrary parliamentary power.
They felt defensive.
They worried about the
seeming inevitability of
a rise of arbitrary power.
Now,
of course,
people in parliament did
not see themselves as x
exercising arbitrary power.
They saw themselves as
behaving constitutionally
asserting their constitutional
power to govern over the colonies.
But as we've seen in this course so far,
there were some fundamental disagreements
on both sides about the precise
meaning of parliaments,
constitutional power to govern over the
colonies about the precise way in which
this imperial system was supposed to work.
So acts like the stamp act,
which parliament basically intended as
a way to raise revenue or the tea act.
Same idea could logically seem to the
colonists like a way of establishing a new
precedent,
right?
And a new precedent that ultimately would
be making some kind of inroad against
liberty and property rights.
And particularly given that the stamp
act was not ultimately raising enormous
sums of money to the colonists,
that was a real sign that it
must be about a precedent, right?
It can't really be about raising enormous
sums of money. It must be a trap,
a precedent setting trap that if they
can get us to accept this precedent,
then the government will be able to set
future taxes along similar lines because
the precedent well have been set.
If your constitution,
if you understand your constitutional
rights as based on precedent,
when you see new precedents
potentially being set,
that's a potentially scary thing,
so you can kind of get a sense of why the
colonists and reacting as they do to a
lot of events in this period.
As John Dickinson wrote,
and I've mentioned before his,
he's really well known pamphlet from
1768 called letters from a farmer in
Pennsylvania,
Dickinson wrote,
nothing is wanted at home
and by home he means Britain,
but a precedent,
the force of which shall be established
by the tacit submission of the colonies.
If the parliament
succeeds in this attempt,
other statutes will impose other duties
and thus the parliament will levy upon
us such sums of money as they choose
to take without any other limitation,
then their pleasure, right? He
says it's just about the precedent.
It's all about precedent.
That's what we're looking at here.
This the fact that small amounts of
money are being raised in a sense,
it's the ultimate proof that what really
matters to parliament is the precedent
that they're setting.
The same holds true for the vice admiralty
courts I've mentioned before that
were being used as venues for trying
certain crimes committed in the colonies.
Vice Admiralty courts were
composed of a single judge.
They had no jury and they were becoming
responsible for enforcing parliamentary
legislation and the new legislation.
Logically,
many colonists would have seen this.
Again, really dangerous precedent,
violating fundamental British
constitutional rights,
violating past precedents,
the presence of a standing army in the
colonies. Also same kind of threat,
same kind of fear.
Something new is happening
here and certainly history,
ancient and modern taught
about the dangers of a
standing army and Samuel Adams
summed up prevailing ideas about standing
armies in a newspaper essay that he
wrote in 1768 and he wrote,
it is a very improbable supposition that
any people can long remain free with a
strong military power in the
very heart of their country.
Unless that military power is under the
direction of the people and even then it
is dangerous history.
Both ancient and modern affords many
instances of the overthrow of states and
kingdoms by the power of soldiers who
were raised and maintained at first under
the plausible pretense of
defending those very liberties,
which they afterwards destroyed.
So in the colonies,
the fear of a standing army with bad
enough at the end of the French and Indian
war, when the crown sent troops to
protect the colonists against the French,
the Spanish and native
American populations.
But a few years later when troops began
to arrive in Boston and Response to
stamp act demonstrations,
it's certainly seem to many colonists
as though it might be the first step in
what could be the destruction of their
liberties there. Colonial charters,
their constitutional rights, uh,
seem to be, again, a scary precedent.
Now, in a way, it's really tempting
to look at this way of thinking like,
these people are like worried
about precedents. What's happening?
What does it mean? It must be a
sign that they're going to do worse.
And think of these people as being really
paranoid in a logical, like, oh, come on.
You know what? If it's just like a little
gesture to raise some money. Colonists.
Why? Why do you seem so paranoid?
And they're in the past.
They're actually have been some historians
who suggested that the colonists were
to some degree being paranoid.
We're seeing threats of tyranny where
there actually wasn't any Tierney at all.
But as I've just described,
precedents are a fundamental part of
British constitutional thought and
enlightenment theory backed up that idea
because enlightenment science promised
the capacity to understand and
control nature and society.
You're supposed to be looking for patterns
of behavior to understand what things
mean.
So the British government seem to be
setting new precedents and the colonists
were looking for the pattern,
trying to figure out the logic of what
was happening, what was parliament up to,
what were they thinking?
Why were they seemingly violating
fundamental constitutional rights?
And you can see this logic
again in Dickinson's pamphlet
and his letters from a
farmer in Pennsylvania, which he argued,
was premised on his desire quote,
to discover the intentions
of those who rule over us.
Why are they doing what they're doing?
There's a pattern. What is the pattern?
What does it mean?
Colonist ultimately resisted what they
saw as the approach of tyranny and their
resistance stiffen.
The British government's resolve,
which in turn provoke more of
a reaction in the colonies.
And eventually down the road,
the colonists would come to see their
social contract with the British
government broken a conclusion,
which would seem to them,
give them the right of community
resistance. But as I've said,
it's important to recognize that the
colonists at this point see their actions
not as revolutionary,
but just the opposite.
They're fighting for their British rights.
They're not trying to figure
out how to stage a revolution.
I think we hear the phrase
continental congress were like, Ooh,
one more continental congress, and
we're there. You know, they, wow.
Almost an independence.
But that's obviously not the way
that they're thinking at the time.
They see themselves as fighting against
arbitrary power in defense of British
liberties, not as rabid revolutionaries.
And thus far in the course,
it's parliament.
That seems to be the main source of
arbitrary power to the colonists.
So as we're going to
see in future lectures,
a logical response to this conclusion
would be for the colonists to next turn to
the king to solve their problems.
Okay.
If parliament is
exercising arbitrary power,
we will now turn it to the king and
appealed to him to solve our problems.
We will see that logic go into
effect very soon in future lectures.
So more has to happen before the colonists
begin to consider the ultimate act of
resistance.
Actual rebellion would seem
to them as the last resort,
the last resort of people
unable to protect their lives,
liberties and properties by
normal constitutional methods.
And there were some members of parliament
that could foresee this looming threat.
And early 1775 Edmund Burke gave one of
his best known speeches in parliament.
It was a three hour speech,
and he argued in his speech that
parliament should try to be conciliatory
towards the colonies or risk
pushing them to extremes.
And he laid out in this speech some of
the points that actually come up just in
the course of this lecture. He said,
Americans love their liberties. Why?
Because they're descendants of liberty,
loving English citizens to those who
argue that giving concessions to the
colonists would encourage them
to demand even more concessions.
Burke said he doubted whether quote
giving to millions of my fellow citizens
some share of those rights,
which I have always been taught to value
would bring down the empire and he had
a dramatic conclusion.
He said,
let the colonies always keep the idea of
their civil rights associated with your
government.
They will cling and grapple to you and
no forest under heaven will be of power
to tear them from their allegiance.
But let it once be understood that your
government may be one thing and their
privilege another, that these two things
may exist without any mutual relation.
The cement is gone,
the cohesion is loosened and everything
hastens to decay and dissolution.
So to the colonists, and in a sense
you can hear to Burke as well,
rebellion would be a drastic action
only to be exercised by an overwhelming
majority of the community against rulers
who so completely ignored the terms of
the original social contract as to make
further allegiance a crime against God.
And reason,
and it's really only by grasping this
mindset and really taking it seriously
that we can begin to
understand events to come.
That will lead to what is seen at the
time is that last dire step towards
revolution. I will stop there.
I will see you on Tuesday.
Happy paper completing
and have a good weekend.